[Musique]
bien chers collègues merci nous
reprenons nos travaux nous accueillons
ce matin
madame cleredon Défenseur des droits qui
est accompagné de Madame polongevin
c'est une ministre et de Monsieur
Delamare
l'audition évidemment porte sur le
rapport annuel quelques mots
introductifs puis je laisserai
évidemment la parole
madame Défenseur des droits donc
vous êtes désormais d'abord votre
rapport a été publié récemment récemment
le 17 avril c'est pas très très ancien
c'est dans ce cadre là que vous venez ce
matin à la Commission à la commission
des lois
le défenseur des droites en institution
et désormais solidement ancré dans notre
paysage institutionnel et naturellement
parfaitement de plus en plus identifié
par nos concitoyens les statistiques
d'ailleurs d'activité le montrent
puisque nos concitoyens sont de plus en
plus nombreux à vous solliciter ils ont
été 226 000 en 2022
en augmentation de 9% par rapport à 2021
et la barre des cent mille appels aux
différentes plateformes anti
discrimination que vous tenez a
également été franchie
je voudrais m'attarder sur trois
éléments qui figurent dans votre rapport
et qui font écho aux travaux que la
commission des lois mène le premier
concerne la question de l'accès au
service public des étrangers qui fait
l'objet de nombreux développements dans
le rapport que nous avions commis et que
le territoire a commis en mai 2022
intitulé service de l'État immigration
retrouver science efficacité un an après
cette alerte les travaux révèlent vos
travaux pendant révèle malheureusement
la longueur du chemin qui reste à
parcourir sur ce sujet ainsi vous
relevez une hausse de 230% des
réclamations des étrangers depuis 2019
et même de 450% en Île-de-France la
plupart d'entre elles concernent
évidemment le désamétristement célèbre
problématique la désométrie selon ses
problématique des rendez-vous en
préfecture
qui nourrissent un contentieux
intéressant enfin je sais pas si
intéressant mais en tous les cas il est
étonnant nous savons tous décrocher un
rendez-vous peut en effet être une
gageure dans certains territoires vous
évoquez le nombre d'une quinzaine de
préfectures dans votre rapport et si la
dématérialisation des procédures
contribuera à terme un résorber les
difficultés il faut cette constater que
sa mise en œuvre à grande vitesse CRT au
principe de réalité trois points de
suspension peut-être numérique tout
court peut-être pourriez-vous revenir
dans votre propos sur ce sujet madame un
autre fait marquant pour 2022 il entrait
en vigueur du nouveau régime de
protection des lanceurs d'alerte
à l'initiative de Madame difolco
le Sénat avait été à l'initiative pour
placer le Défenseur des droits au cœur
du système des premières évolutions sont
déjà visibles avec une augmentation de
51% des réclamations relatives à
l'orientation et la protection des
lanceurs ces premières tendances sont
encourageantes et nous observons la
suite avec vigilance et puis enfin la
question de la réforme des amendes
forfaitaire délictuelles qui fait parler
vous portez une appréciation sévère sur
l'extension de cette procédure à de
nouveaux d'élite tels que le Sénat
l'admi d'ailleurs tout en ne s'opposant
à la génération souhaitée par le
gouvernement la position du Sénat est en
effet que ces modalités peuvent être
adaptées à certaines infractions dites
de basse intensité que nous qualifions
de basse intensité qui sinon ne font ga
l'objet de poursuites en pratique nous
avons besoin de vos précisions madame
sur ce point et peut-être avez-vous déjà
observé les effets de l'entrée en
vigueur de ces AFD
nouvelle génération voici ces quelques
éléments propos introductifs madame
Madame et Monsieur et je vous laisse
immédiatement la parole puis ensuite
évidemment comme il est d'usage il y
aura un échange de questions et de
réponse bien sûr merci
monsieur le Président merci mesdames
laissées natrices et messieurs les
sénateurs effectivement monsieur le
Président je vais revenir sur un certain
nombre de points que vous avez évoqué
d'abord je tiens vraiment à vous
remercier de m'accueillir aujourd'hui
comme chaque année pour présenter notre
rapport annuel qui dit quelque chose de
l'état de la société et pas simplement
un rapport annuel d'activité de notre de
notre institution comme vous l'avez dit
je suis accompagné de Georges paulinge
vin qui est mon adjointe en charge de la
lutte contre les discriminations d'Éric
de Lemarque et le Défenseur des enfants
et de Mireille le corps qui est notre
secrétaire général
issu du Conseil d'État et je vous le
disais ce ce moment et ce rapport est un
moment important dans la vie de
l'institution et qui rencontre de notre
activité comme le prévoit d'ailleurs la
Constitution où je dois remettre ce
rapport au président de la République et
je le verrai au début du mois de juillet
et au Parlement Assemblée nationale je
l'ai déjà fait et donc vous aujourd'hui
ça me paraît ces échanges
particulièrement importants et ce
rapport est révélateur d'une partie des
atteints au droit des difficultés vécues
par de nombreuses personnes vous le
savez nous sommes une autorité
administrative inscrite dans la
Constitution à valeur constitution nous
sommes chargées de défendre les droits
et les libertés et j'insiste toujours
sur le fait que nous avons deux missions
la première c'est vraiment de traiter
les réclamations que nous recevons et
vous l'avez dit en augmentation on est
près de 126000 et le législateur a bien
prévu que c'était pas simplement traité
des réclamations mais promouvoir les
droits et les libertés et c'est donc
bien faire des rapports et des
préconisations à partir des difficultés
que nous observons je dirais pour tarir
les difficultés à la sauce vous
connaissez nos cinq domaines de
compétence donc il y a effectivement
lutte contre les discriminations
protection des droits des enfants vous
avez cité aussi protection et
orientation des lanceurs d'alerte nous
sommes aussi le contrôle externe de la
déontologie des forces de sécurité et
j'y reviendrai et nous sommes là aussi
sur le respect des droits des usagers de
services publics et je tiens à dire
d'ailleurs que c'est plus de 85% de nos
réclamations et c'est ce qui fait
vraiment notre quotidien ces missions
sont diverses mais en fait elles se
complètent en un point commun c'est la
défense des droits et des libertés et je
dirais que c'est à la fois le point de
départ et l'aboutissement de chacune des
missions c'est à la fois la boussole qui
nous guide dans notre activité et dans
un contexte où ils sont en danger une
préservation et d'autres leur
préservation et notre raison d'être
alors pour mener à bien nos missions le
législateur nous a donné des pouvoirs de
médiation d'enquête de recommandations
et d'ailleurs nous traitons une grande
partie de nos réclamations en médiation
on s'appuie sur 250 agents
majoritairement au siège et certains
chefs de pôle régionaux dans les régions
et puis des pôles régionaux avec 570
délégués qui vous le savez sont des
bénévoles ont une indemnité et traite
plus de 80% des déréclamations et
particulièrement celle des droits
d'usagers de services publics et nous
avons aussi 120 jeunes ambassadeurs et
ambassadrices des droits des Jade qui
vont interviennent dans des écoles
collèges lycées pour parler des droits
de l'enfant et des luttes contre les
discriminations et on pourra y revenir
parce qu'évidemment ils sont fortement
interpellés dans ces questions aussi sur
les questions de harcèlement scolaire
nos constats sont fondés sur un travail
rigoureux réalisé à partir de situations
individuelle d'atteinte au droit et ce
sont ces situations vécues qui contient
que contient ce rapport nous en recevons
toujours davantage effectivement près de
126000 cette année une augmentation de
10% c'était 100 000 en 2020 115
000 en 2021 126000 en 2022
l'augmentation est constante alors vous
le savez que l'actualité m'a conduite à
m'exprimer beaucoup ces derniers temps
sur notre rôle en tant que contrôle
externe des forces de sécurité j'y
reviendrai bien sûr mais permettez-moi
de commencer et de commenter notre
action dans nos différents champs de
compétences et de commencer par la
question d'accès au service public de
droits des usagers de services publics
et je viendrai après à la question des
droits des enfants de la déontologie des
forces de sécurité de la lutte contre
les discriminations et je finirai avec
les lanceurs d'alerte
sur la question des droits des usagers
de services publics je suis frappé par
l'éloignement des services publics et je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui qui
vous parle vous particulièrement avec
votre ancrage dans les dans les
territoires les services publics
incarnent l'accès au droit ils ont pour
mission de les rendre concrets et aussi
accessibles or nous constatons de
manière persistante la déshumanisation
des services publics elle se traduit par
une dégradation des relations avec les
usagers l'absence de réponse des
administrations entraîne la résignation
le non recours la perte de droit pour
les usagers et je précise toujours quand
je dis cela que je ne mets pas en cause
l'action des agents publics mais bien au
contraire d'ailleurs le manque d'agent
public leur effacement du fait d'une
dématérialisation excessive la relation
avec les services publics et notre
quotidien à tous et les difficultés dans
cette relation peuvent tous nous
concerner que ce soit avec l'école la
CAF les impôts l'assurance maladie Pôle
Emploi sa commune nous pouvons nous
trouver à différents moments de notre
vie dans une situation
d'incompréhension vis-à-vis de
l'administration mais les camps les
conséquences sont redoutables en
particulier pour les personnes
vulnérables quand elles se traduisent
notamment par des ruptures de droits
sociaux nous constatons d'ailleurs que
ces difficultés sont renforcées par la
dématérialisation qui est l'une des
expressions du recul des services
publics les droits ne peuvent être
garantis que s'il y a des personnes pour
répondre aux situations particulières
entendons-nous bien la dématérialisation
est une chance elle peut simplifier des
démarches mais le problème c'est de
pouvoir toujours avoir accès à une
personne et à un accueil même s'il y a
cette dématérialisation et cette
politique publique elle a été menée sans
avoir été évaluée dans sa globalité dont
le coût et l'efficacité n'ont pas été
mesuré nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur
ce sujet nous avons précisément décrit
les atteints au droit qui découlent de
la dématérialisation des services
publics on y a consacré deux rapports un
en 2019 le deuxième en 2022 je pense
qu'ils ont contribué à la prise de
conscience des enjeux liés à la
transformation de nos services publics
en fait la dématérialisation elle se
fait au prix pour certaines personnes
d'une exclusion je voudrais vous citer
les derniers chiffres du CREDOC qui
évoque 16,5 millions de personnes
éloignées du numérique c'est
31,5% des Français de plus de 18 ans
c'est donc près d'un tiers de la
population française éloignée du
numérique dedans il y a 11,5 millions
qui sont en difficulté avec le numérique
4 millions de personnes qui n'ont pas
accès à Internet c'est quand même ça la
réalité en ce moment de la société près
d'un tiers de la population française
éloignée du numérique la
dématérialisation s'accompagne même si
c'est une chance pour un grand nombre
d'entre nous d'un report sur l'usagé de
tâches qui incombées auparavant à
l'administration en fait on demande à
l'usager de s'adapter alors que le
principe même du service public c'est de
s'adapter à l'usager et du coup l'usager
doit s'équiper se former être capable de
d'effectuer des démarches en ligne tout
en comprenant le langage administratif
et puis ne pas commettre d'erreur et je
trouve que ça pose la question de quel
service public voulons-nous le premier
défi que doit relever la transformation
numérique des services publics c'est de
garantir leur accessibilité dans le
respect des principes qui le guide et en
particulier ce principe d'égalité et
aujourd'hui nous constatons que les
alternatives au numérique sont très
insuffisantes avec l'Institut de
National de la Consommation nous avons
mené une étude sur l'évaluation des
réponses apportées aux usagers par les
plateformes téléphoniques de quatre
services publics et les résultats
montrent que sur les 1500 appels passés
40% n'ont pas abouti et un certain
nombre de réponses étaient de mauvaises
réponses et pouvait induire l'usager en
erreur nous disons souvent des personnes
qu'elles sont éloignées du droit et j'ai
vraiment l'impression que c'est le
service public qui s'est éloigné d'elle
notamment des plus vulnérables des plus
en faisant peser sur une charge
administrative et une charge matérielle
et mentale très lourde et je pense
là-dessus aussi aux personnes âgées qui
se trouvent très démunies face à cette
dématérialisation la dématérialisation
ne peut être considérée comme un progrès
si elle exclut est déshumanise le
service public alors que 28% de la
population éprouve des difficultés face
aux démarches administratives c'est
vraiment au service public de s'adapter
de s'adapter et non pas à l'inverse je
pense particulièrement à une personne
âgée qui devait changer sa chaudière
pour cela elle pouvait bénéficier de ma
prime rénov elle a donc créé un compte
sur le site de Lana de l'Agence
nationale de l'habitat et malgré
plusieurs tentatives elle n'est pas
parvenue à compléter son dossier en
raison de dysfonctionnement du site
entre temps sa chaudière a cessé de
fonctionner elle s'est trouvée d'eau
chaude et de chauffage en plein hiver
elle a donc fait les travaux avant la
réponse de Lana ce qui a comme principe
en conséquence de la privée du Béné de
ma prime rénov puisqu'il faut d'abord
avoir l'accord avant de mener les
travaux on est vraiment face à un cas
d'une personne
âgée qui se trouve privé du net
financière auquel elle a droit en raison
d'un dysfonctionnement technique de la
plateforme dans une procédure qui a été
entièrement dématérialisée sans
alternative alors l'intervention d'un
délégué du Défenseur des droits a permis
le versement de l'aide nous avons reçu
des centaines de réclamations similaires
on a constaté de nombreux écueils dans
le traitement des demandes des problèmes
techniques sur la plateforme des défauts
d'information des délais traitements et
des difficultés liées à la
dématérialisation totale de la procédure
et ses entraves vont entraîner
d'importantes conséquences pour les
usagers et pour respecter les droits les
services publics je l'ai souvent dit ne
peuvent pas être intégralement et
exclusivement dématérialisés
à partir de nos enquêtes on a fait un
certain nombre de recommandations à Lana
et je suis heureuse de voir que le dépôt
papier sera possible à partir de janvier
2024 dans les espaces françaises c'était
une de nos préconisations nous
préconisations nous préconisions aussi
une meilleure information et des progrès
ont été faits mais honnêtement nous
continuons à avoir à arriver des
réclamations et quand je rencontre nos
délégués je continue à chaque fois une
des premières choses qui me dit c'est on
n'a pas de réponse de Lana sur les
saisines que nous avons les réclamations
soulignent aussi que la
dématérialisation touche en particulier
des personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité et contribue aussi à créer
des vulnérabilités on le voit bien dans
ces situations et je pense là notamment
aux situations à la situation des
personnes étrangères qui rencontrent de
nombreux obstacles pour accéder à leurs
droits et aux préfectures vous l'avez
dit sur l'augmentation des réclamations
que nous avons dans ce domaine et du
coup le droit des étrangers devenus le
premier domaine de réclamation auprès de
l'institution près d'un quart c'est même
30% depuis le début de l'année donc ça
ne cesse d'augmenter soyons très clair
c'est principalement des gens qui
veulent juste renouveler leur carte de
séjour qui l'obtiendront qui n'arrivent
pas à avoir de rendez-vous en préfecture
et pour qui ça a des conséquences
excessivement délétères je pouvais vous
donner plusieurs situations très
concrètes de gens qui perdent leur
emploi qui perdent leur logement d'une
je peux vous donner aussi l'exemple
d'une jeune fille qui ne pouvait pas
passer son CAP petite enfance sachez
juste qu'on est des métiers en tension
dont on a besoin des personnes parce
qu'elles ne pouvait pas récupérer à
temps sa carte de séjour dont elle a
besoin pour pour passer l'examen ce sont
vraiment pour moi des situations
inacceptables qui placent les gens qui
étaient en situation régulière en
situation
irrégulière et là-dessus pareil je
n'accuse aucunement les agents dans les
préfectures qui font au mieux la Cour
des comptes très bien dit le le la
réduction des effectifs a été beaucoup
trop importante et je peux vous dire que
quand je rencontre les préfets les uns
après les autres ils m'aèrent aussi sur
la réduction des effectifs qui rend
impossible le traitement des des
dossiers et la dématérialisation elle a
eu une autre conséquence sur ce sujet
c'est qu'elle a mis hors la vue
l'indignité pour moi a été invisibilisé
puisque avant nous voyons des queues
devant les préfectures nous les voyons
plus puisque la queue elle est devant
son ordinateur pour essayer de débloquer
un rendez-vous en préfecture et je le
redis le service public doit toujours
conserver son rôle de soutien et de
services au public
c'est c'est ces conséquences de la
dématérialisation empêche l'accès de
nombreux usagers au service public elles
sont graves individuellement je vous ai
cité quelques conséquences et elles sont
grave collectivement avec une population
qui ne voit plus s'incarner le principe
des qualités qui perd confiance dans la
puissance publique nous sommes
confrontés à un dysfonctionnement
structurel auquel mon institution avec
ses moyens ne peut pas pallier seul et
qui surtout n'en a pas la vocation nous
ne pouvons et nous ne devons pas nous
substituer au service public notre rôle
c'est de répondre réclamation
individuelle de révéler des atteintes
aux droits de faire des recommandations
pour que les pouvoirs publics sont
saisissent et sans réaction très
honnêtement mon institution risque
l'embolie de ne plus être en mesure de
répondre aux personnes qui s'adressent à
elle franchement est-ce que c'est normal
qu'un usager doivent nous saisir soit
nous soit le juge des référés simplement
pour obtenir un rendez-vous je pense que
ce système
marche sur la tête et je dis que je n'ai
pas vocation à devenir le doctolib des
rendez-vous en préfecture
le problème doit être résolu à la source
au niveau des préfectures mais face à
cette forme de déshumanisation des
services publics nous mettons nous tout
en œuvre pour aller au plus près des
personnes qui en ont besoin et avant
d'aborder la question des droits des
enfants je voudrais vous dire ce que
nous faisons pour essayer d'être le plus
accessible d'aller vers d'abord je vous
le redis nous sommes joignables par
courrier par mail par téléphone partout
en France avec nos 570 délégués qui sont
présents dans 990 points d'accueil que
sont les préfectures les maisons de la
justice et du droit on continue à créer
de nouvelles permanences dans des
centres sociaux dans des espaces
françaises dans des tiers-le dans des
missions locales l'objectif pour nous
c'est d'être toujours plus accessible
afin de garantir à chacun le respect des
droits et je pense que avec leur
permanence nos délégués comblent un
manque ton souffre de plus en plus nos
services publics en fait la présence de
guichet qui permette un accueil physique
et une écoute et ainsi grâce à leur
implication et à leur action de nos
délégués 75% de nos médiations ont
abouti en 2022 nous faisons tout pour
être joignable par téléphone c'est près
de 8000 appels mensuels avec un taux de
décroché de plus de 90%
avec une plateforme généraliste et nous
avons mis aussi en place vous savez le
site anti discrimination avec le 39 28
et nous avons mis en place un numéro
dédié maintenant qui est gratuit pour
les personnes détenues le 31 41 pour
revenir à la plateforme anti
discrimination vous savez que nous avons
créé cette plateforme à la demande du
Président de la République pour aider et
accompagner les victimes et témoins de
discrimination et cette plateforme elle
offre la possibilité pour les victimes
d'être entendus d'obtenir des réponses
personnalisées avec des écoutants qui
passent le temps nécessaire de nombreux
appels dure plus de trois quarts d'heure
pour mieux orienter les personnes
ce dont je continue à avoir conscience
malgré l'augmentation des réclamations
que nous avons c'est que nous sommes
encore mal connues les le grand public
ne s'est pas forcément qu'il peut nous
saisir et nous déployer des campagnes de
communication pour faire connaître
l'institution et faire connaître
l'institution c'est aussi la faire
connaître auprès des enfants que je
regarde
Eric delemarque et notre défenseur des
enfants et je voudrais aborder avec vous
le second point qui est la nécessaire
défense des droits des enfants
ce que nous observons assez de façon
assez générale dans les réclamations que
nous avons dans ce domaine c'est que
trop souvent les enfants ne sont pas
considérés comme des sujets de droit et
nous intervenons pour des enfants qui
n'ont pas accès au logement à
l'éducation à la cantine à la protection
à laquelle ils ont droit je vous
rappelle que le Comité des droits de
l'enfant de l'ONU a publié ses
observations finales sur l'application
de la Convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant par la France le 2
juin et il enjoint la France d'adopter
des mesures
urgentes dans 6 domaines qui
correspondent complètement à nos
recommandations et je pourrais y revenir
si vous le si vous le souhaitez
malgré des progrès la scolarisation des
enfants en situation de handicap est
encore très insuffisante
au-delà de l'augmentation du nombre
d'accompagnements d'élèves en situation
de handicap les pouvoirs publics doivent
vous rendre possible la formation des
enseignants pour mieux garantir
l'effectivité des droits de l'enfant en
fait au lieu de s'adapter à l'enfant on
a l'impression que le système scolaire
demande à l'enfant et à la famille de
s'adapter
nous voyons encore trop d'enfants privés
de liberté dans les centres de rétention
administratives parfois rattachées
arbitrairement à un tiers pour être
retenu et je pense notamment à Mayotte
permettez-moi de m'attarder quelques
instants sur Mayotte et les atteintes au
droit particulièrement fréquentes et
graves que nous observons à cet égard
d'ailleurs les actions liées à
l'opération dites ou embushu m'inquiète
particulièrement et nous y attachons la
plus grande vigilance j'ai saisi à sujet
le ministre de l'Intérieur les autres
ministres concernés par des risques
d'atteinte au droit et j'ai souhaité
qu'une délégation de juriste de
l'institution se rendre sur place mon
préoccupations portent sur deux points
d'une part les conditions des décasages
alors même que le nombre de
constructions est très insuffisant pour
que des familles soient cueillies et
d'autre part les conditions
d'éloignement prévus de personnes
étrangères et notamment en termes de
droits aux cours de rétention dans les
crats et les et les Léra les lieux de
rétention administrative à cet égard je
vous rappelle que la France vient encore
d’être condamné par la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme pour la rétention
d'enfants encras le projet de loi
immigration dans l'examen a eu lieu
devant votre assemblée et dont on ne
sait pas ce que sera le le prochain
comporter une disposition pour y mettre
fin mais mais à échéance de 2028 et
seulement pour les mineurs jusqu'à 16
ans donc nos préconisations est-ce que
dit la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme mineur c'est jusqu'à 18 ans
s'agissant des droits de l'enfant
toujours nous constatons également
qu'ils doivent être mieux protégés
qu'ils ne se sont ne le sont pas
suffisamment et vous m'avez déjà entendu
là-dessus je suis particulièrement
inquiète de l'état de la protection de
l'enfance qui ne parvient plus
aujourd'hui à jouer son rôle des
juridictions dans les décisions ne sont
pas exécutées un manque de place en
foyer d'assistant familiaux des mesures
d'assistante et d'assistance éducatives
en milieu ouvert prise en charge dans
des délais pouvant excéder six mois des
ruptures dans parcours des enfants des
changements de famille d'accueil sans
aucune préparation de l'enfant ni
considération pour le lien d'attachement
qui s'est construit entre l'enfant et sa
famille d'accueil quels sont les
situations extrêmement préoccupantes que
nous constatons et qui porte atteinte au
droit des enfants là encore nous sommes
face à des problèmes systémiques nous
publions des recommandations qui
nécessitent des réponses des pouvoirs
publics à la hauteur des enjeux la
protection des enfants et le respect de
leurs droits j'en viens au troisième
point que je voulais aborder avec vous
l'année le nécessaire respect des droits
par les forces de sécurité vous savez
que législateur a fait du Défenseur des
droits le contrôleur indépendant des
policiers gendarmes surveillants
pénitentiaires des agents de sécurité
privée de toute personne effectue un
exerçant une activité de sécurité la
situation des derniers mois m'a conduite
vous l'avez souvent vu à réexpliquer le
rôle de mon institution en tant que
contrôle indépendant de la déontologie
des forces de sécurité cette fonction me
paraît essentielle dans une la
démocratie un état de droit il faut
expliquer sans cesse que c'est l'état
dans lequel les pouvoirs publics sont
soumis au droit et ainsi la première
exigence déontologique et le respect du
droit le respect de la loi par les
policiers et gendarmes ils sont au
service de la loi des institutions et de
la population
nous avons rendu en 2022 deux décisions
pour des faits qui mettent directement
en cause ses principes et je pense à la
destruction en dehors de tout cadre
légal de logements de famille vivant
dans des baraquements par des bulldozers
ou même par le feu par des policiers les
conséquences sont lourdes les personnes
sont privées de leur logement bien sûr
quand bien même il était précaire de
leurs effets personnels de tous les
accompagnements que prévoient la loi en
matière de santé mais aussi en matière
de scolarisation des enfants et grâce à
la rigueur de nos enquêtes à notre
indépendance nous avons pu faire la
lumière sur des faits sur les
responsabilités qui sont attachées
depuis plus de 20 ans le défenseur des
droits et la Commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité la CNDS avant
lui enquête sur le comportement des
policiers et des gendarmes et le
législateur a pensé que pour établir la
confiance entre les acteurs de la
sécurité et les citoyens il faut un
contrôle indépendant et transparent et
il a considéré que le respect de la
déontologie est protecteur d'abord pour
les policiers et les gendarmes et
particulièrement nécessaire au regard
des responsabilités et prérogatives
qu'ils détiennent ah si nous avons
publié de nombreuses décisions sur des
comportements de policiers et gendarmes
ainsi que sur le rôle de la hiérarchie
et des avis sur le maintien de l'ordre
nous avons constaté lors des épisodes de
manifestation des années précédentes des
privations de liberté arbitraire des
dissimulations du visage des policiers
contraire à la loi nous avons rendu
plusieurs décisions sur l'usage de la
force des armes dites de force
intermédiaires comme les LBD nous avons
publié un rapport intitulé le maintien
de l'ordre regard de la déontologie qui
a été remis au Président de l'Assemblée
nationale en janvier 2018 nous avons
pris position sur le schéma national de
maintien et sur plusieurs projets et de
loi et je pense entre autres à la loi de
sécurité globale et c'est fort de cette
expertise des pouvoirs que nous donne la
Constitution et la loi organique que
nous traitons des réclamations que nous
avons reçues depuis les manifestations
sur la retraite 169 à ce jour sur le
comportement des policiers et des
gendarmes lors des manifestations les
témoignages et images qui nous
parviennent laisse penser que les droits
ont été bafoués et ma crainte et que la
répétition de tels actes contribue à les
rendre habituelles et à rendre habituel
l'inacceptable il risque d'installer une
logique de face à face dans la durée
pouvant entraîner des atteintes à la
liberté de manifester à l'intégrité
physique à la vie et je le rappelle la
sécurité des manifestants des policiers
et des gendarmes la garantie de la
liberté de manifester sont de la
responsabilité de l'État
et le respect sans faille de la
déontologie et la condition dans la
durée de la légitimité des interventions
des forces de sécurité et nous
contribuons donc par notre travail à
conforter cette légitimité en veillant
sur le respect de la déontologie nous
mènerons des enquêtes impartiales et
contradictoires pour ces faits en
prenant le temps nécessaire sur ces 169
réclamations que nous avons reçues j'ai
conscience qu'il y a un décalage là
dessus entre le temps médiatique et le
temps permettant de publier des
décisions résultat d'enquête abouties et
si ces questions prennent une telle
place dans le débat politique et
médiatique c'est notre c'est que notre
société tout entière s'en trouve abîmée
ébranlé dans ses repères et dans la
confiance en ces institutions et par
notre action je vous le répète je suis
convaincu que nous contribuons à
préserver les repères indispensables
ceux de la loi des droits et des
libertés et à cet égard je rappelle
combien le respect de la liberté de
manifester et de la liberté
d'associations doivent être réserver je
m'inquiète à cet égard un climat qui
contribue à fragiliser l'édifice
démocratique le contrôle indépendant est
toujours plus nécessaire mais même s'il
fait l'objet d'attaque ça ne m'a pas
échappé nous participons au débat
démocratique en rendant public nos
décisions et également ce rapport annuel
cette défense des droits et des libertés
elle passe aussi par la lutte contre les
discriminations qui étaient le 4e point
sur lequel je voulais venir le deuxième
volet de la grande enquête trajectoire
et origine dit Théo qui a été réalisé
par l'Inde et l'Insee avec le soutien de
l'institution du Défenseur des droits
montre que les discriminations sont en
augmentation 19% des personnes de 18 à
49 ans ont déclaré souvent ou parfois
des discriminations au cours des cinq
dernières années elles étaient 14% en
2008 dans la précédente enquête le
premier volet de Théo l'enquête permet
d'affirmer que la discrimination est
très présente dans notre pays qu'elle ne
régresse pas elle témoigne également
d'un manque d'intervention des pouvoirs
publics dans la lutte contre
discrimination vous savez que nous
réalisons aussi chaque année un
baromètre des discriminations avec
l'oité l'Organisation internationale du
Travail et l'édition de 2022 a été
consacrée aux personnes employées par le
secteur des services à la personne et
qui révèlent des discriminations qu'elle
subisse et sans ce type d'étude une
bonne part des discriminations serait
invisible parce qu'en fait les recours
juridiques ou les recours devant notre
intestitution sautera si je prends
l'année 2022 seulement 6500 saisines
pour discrimination devant notre
institution et c'est trop peu nos
saisies ne sont que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg l'ampleur des discriminations
ne se reflète pas dans le nombre de
démarches effectuées par les personnes
victimes il y a une forme de fatalisme
et surtout en fait une crainte des
représailles
mais nous agissons par voie d'enquête
par voie de médiation aussi pour lutter
contre les discriminations pour les
situations que nous recevons je peux
juste vous en citer un qui nous qui nous
avait un peu étonné cette année d'un cas
d'un professeur de guitare qu'une
commune a refusé d'embaucher car il
allait devenir père et il voulait
prendre son compter que j'ai paternité
de 28 jours et nous avons constaté la
discrimination et obtenue d'ailleurs
qu'il soit indemnisés je rappelle que le
Défenseur des droits est un recours en
la matière et je vous rappelle le site
internet anti discrimination.fr et le
numéro de téléphone le 39 28 nous devons
toujours rappeler que l'égalité est un
principe fondamental la discrimination
une infraction et il y a urgence à faire
de la lutte contre les discriminations
une priorité politique il faut combattre
les discriminations elles sont une
souffrance pour les personnes une
injustice elles entravent leur parcours
de vie leur possibilité de se réaliser
en tant qu'individu et puis je
terminerai avec la dernière compétence
que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
président
c'est le rôle central que nous jouons
sur la protection et l'orientation des
lanceurs d'alerte nous connaissons
l'importance des lanceurs d'alerte pour
le respect du droit pour la préservation
de l'intérêt général depuis 2016 la
première et la première loi de
protection des lanceurs d'alerte qui
confie justement en défenseur des droits
la protection et la mission de protéger
et d'orienter les lanceurs d'alerte et
nous occupons une place centrale dans ce
dispositif notre rôle a été renforcé par
la loi du 21 mars 2022
visant justement à renforcer la
protection des lanceurs d'alerte et à la
confié un nouveau au pouvoir au
Défenseur des droits celui délivrait une
certification
reconnaissant la qualité de lanceur
d'alerte et conferrant la protection
associée nous avons d'ailleurs publié un
guide complet à ce sujet à destination
des lanceurs d'alerte nous recevons
actuellement environ une saisine par
jour dans ce domaine ce qui
effectivement il y avait déjà eu une
augmentation vous l'aviez noté de 50% en
2022 qu'il a va doubler ou tripler les
réclamations que nous recevons en
lanceur d'alerte c'est pour nous cette
augmentation est quand même considérable
et représente aujourd'hui avarice
d'incapacité de l'institution à remplir
ses fonctions et permettez-moi justement
de terminer en vous disant un mot sur
nos moyens d'action nos champs d'action
n'ont cessé de s'élargir avec justement
la question de l'orientation et de la
protection des lanceurs d'alerte le
dispositif anti discrimination le suivi
des conventions internationales
l'activité a cru continuellement se
traduisant par une hausse des
réclamations de plus de 70% depuis 2014
j'évoquais les 126 000 réclamations en
2022 et si on prend depuis 2020 c'est
une augmentation de 29%, les appels
reçus sur la plateforme téléphonique en
témoigne aussi et commence et
connaissent une augmentation
substantielle on est après 100000 appels
en 2022 dans le même temps entre 2014 et
2022 le plafond d'emploi de
l'institution a augmenté de seulement
13% et donc c'est largement insuffisant
pour remplir nos missions nous sommes
clairement face à un risque très
prégnant de dégradation du niveau du
service rendu au réclamant de
difficultés voire d'impossibilité à
satisfaire ni même soutenir les
personnes les plus éloignées de leurs
droits et je rappelle qu'en rétablissant
les personnes dans leur droit nous
sommes un facteur de cohésion sociale et
c'est pour ça que j'ai alerté la
première ministre de cette situation et
je profite vous voulez profiter de ces
échanges de ce matin pour vous alerter
également j'ai bien conscience du
contexte actuel des finances publiques
nous avons transmis qui sont très
réalistes et très précises d'une part
parce que je constate chaque jour
combien nos moyens sont inférieurs à nos
homologues européens l'étude pole DM l'a
montré et a mis en exergue que
l'indépendance était inversement
proportionnelle aux effectifs et nous
découvrons qu'en Europe nous sommes
peut-être les plus indépendants mais
surtout les mois lotis dans ce domaine
j'ai fait aussi des comparaisons sur
notre rôle
d'embousmane de médiateurs nous avons
aussi moins de moyens que nos homologues
européens et ses moyens sont nécessaires
pour que en institution contribue comme
élément pacificateur au service de la
cohésion sociale de notre pays la
Constitution nous a confié la charge de
veiller au respect des droits et des
libertés et j'observe que les droits et
les libertés d'ailleurs ceux qui les
défendent sont régulièrement attaqués ce
rapport annuel d'activité rappelle que
les droits et les libertés ne peuvent
être mis au second point au second plan
ils sont le fondement de notre société
de notre organisation sociale
placé en préambule notre Constitution
ils sont essentiels à la démocratie et à
l'état de droit à travers les situations
individuelles que nous recevons nous
contribuons à rétablir les personnes
dans leur droit mais aussi à renseigner
les pouvoirs publics l'ensemble des
citoyens sur les réponses plus globales
à apporter pour faire progresser le
respect des droits le rapport montre
l'efficacité de notre action en
particulier des médiations dans de
nombreux domaines et l'implication sans
relâche des agents et des délégués du
Défenseur des droits pour obtenir des
avancées pour les droits de toute et
tous pour rappeler sans cesse où se
situe l'inacceptable comment remédier
concrètement aux atteintes aux droits
mais nous ne pouvons faire face seul
nous ne pouvons pas nous substituer aux
administrations au pouvoir public la
révélation d'atteinte structurelles aux
droits doit être prise en compte le
rapport d'en avoir la réalité des
épreuves que traverse celles et ceux qui
ne parviennent pas à faire respecter
leurs droits prendre en compte cette
réalité non seulement une exigence
démocratique mais aussi la seule voie
pour établir la confiance dans nos
services publics et dans nos
institutions je vous remercie merci
Madame pour cette présentation
exhaustive alors
cela a suscité un certain nombre de
questions en tous les cas de collègues
qui veulent s'exprimer ils sont à ce
stade 6 Monsieur François bonhomme
Monsieur Jérôme du Rhin madame Esther
Benbassa monsieur Usain Bourgi monsieur
Tani mamie et Monsieur Guy benaroche je
n'exclut pas qu'il y en ait pas d'autres
qui se manifeste au cours des questions
je vais la parole en premier à Monsieur
François bonhomme
chère madame je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt j'ai même lu les 103
pages de rapports que vous avez rendus
et c'est votre premier rapport à part
entière si je dois dire depuis la prise
de fonction SI parce que je vous ai pris
en fonction 2021 je crois 21 alors en
juillet 2020 je suis venu tous les ans
vous présenter le rapport devant la
commission des lois et nous avons ce qui
est notre devoir fait un rapport tous
les ans que nous présentons en
commission des lois au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale et que j'ai
présenté tous les ans président de la
République très bien ça ne change rien à
la protéine de mes propos
en tout cas ce rapport est sous votre
autorité j'en ai pris connaissance avec
beaucoup d'intérêt alors ce mail des
éléments très différents sur lequel je
peux partir je peux vous rejoindre
notamment sur les questions de l'action
numérique de ma prisme qui dénote
effectivement des dysfonctionnements
administratives qui sont de pénalisant
pour l'accès aux droits en revanche il
n'en n'est pas de même pour d'autres
aspects vous êtes la cantinatrice de
d'une autorité indépendante que vous
représentez aujourd'hui qui est
l'honneur de nos démocratie il faut le
dire quand même c'est peut-être même la
première chose qu'on aurait dit ici
c'est qu'il y a pas beaucoup de
démocraties par principe
osent l'autocritique et donner les
moyens de l'autocritique néanmoins cette
situation ne doit pas non plus amener de
responsabilité vous avez le statut de DM
d'indépendance ce statut doit aussi vous
amener en contrepartie
l'objectif d'impartialité
et celui de responsabilité
et je dois dire que la lecture de
rapport comme les précédents dans
certains cas je j'ai quelques réserves à
émettre par exemple vous je vais essayer
d'être précis vous citer l'exemple de
mer qui
demeure M a r e qui ont fini par exclure
des enfants parce que les parents de
manière chronique irrégulière ou ne
respectez pas le règlement de la cantine
ou ne payez pas
vous savez quand vous êtes maire vous
êtes déjà médiateur quelque sorte et ce
travail là les mers le connaissent
parfaitement et je peux vous dire qu'ils
font le travail que vous faites de
manière institutionnelle et officielle
en essayant de trouver non seulement les
voies du dialogue mais aussi les voix de
règlement avec les parents mais il
arrive figurez-vous que les individus ne
respectent pas les règles auxquelles ils
sont soumis et ça il faudrait quand même
aussi le remettre en perspective ça peut
paraître secondaire pour le questionne
parce que c'est bien heureusement des
choses très
très marginal en revanche les prises de
position que vous avez prises durant
l'année je dois dire m'amène à faire
quelques réflexions je pense notamment
aux questions de maintien de l'ordre
nous avons eu sainte Soline
c'est une Soline qui a été quand même un
déferlement de violence caractérisée
alors vous dites regretter regretter
l'escale de la violence laissant
entendre que l'État a une responsabilité
première dans ce cas de la violence
alors même qu'elle est soumis à des
contraintes que vous avez rappelé
extrêmement importantes en termes
d'usage de la force
mais quand vous avez des cartes
incendiées de gendarmerie quand vous
avez déjà
des gens incendiaires des blessés graves
ou des transports d'armes tout à fait
illicites qui ne sont pas là pour être
la panoplie de manifestants
vos prises de position en disant
simplement que vous êtes contre l'usage
de la grenade des encerclements ou de la
BD qui sont quand même il faudrait le
rappeler qui sont des armes
intermédiaires qui évitent
l'affrontement
à aucun moment vous ne remettez en
perspective cela et ça je crois que ça
donne une mauvaise lecture de votre rôle
et je crois que c'est bien dommage pour
la
dire l'autorité que que l'on vous doit
aussi donc j'aimerais bien aussi que
vous remettiez en perspective ce genre
de choses je prends notre également les
éléments concernant les occupations et
les sites ici nous avons un texte en
cours sur l'occupation et les sites des
logements vous faites partie où vous
avez fait une déclaration tout à fait
officielle dans la presse se régale par
nature parce qu'il y a pas de
contradictoire dans ce domaine vous avez
indiqué que c'était vraiment un
criminalisé le locataire que ça de toute
façon ça n'aurait aucune effet pour les
propriétaires et qu'en fait enfin il y
avait des logements d'accord
madame la Défenseur des droits vous avez
aussi des gens qui sont
âgés qui trouvent leur logement
occupés qui ont essayé aussi d'avoir de
toutes les portes pour épuiser toutes
les procédures de conciliation d'aide
financière mais vous avez ce phénomène
qui s'accroît et qui s'aggrave vous ne
pouvez pas ignorer cette situation en
disant de toute façon ça ne sert à rien
et il n'y a pas de problème il y a un
truc qui s'appelle le droit de propriété
c'est pas une petite article c'est
l'article 17 de la Constitution pourquoi
ne faites-vous pas aussi état du droit
de propriété comme lorsqu'il s'agit du
maintien de l'ordre du droit de
propriété quand il s'agit de protéger
des propriétés privées des réserves
d'eau que l'on s'échine à mettre en
place à après avoir respecté toutes les
autorisations et que des une partie des
manifestants faisant une mauvaise
lecture de leurs droits contestent par
la violence tout à fait déchaînée ça
aussi j'aurais voulu la voir enfin vous
avez indiqué votre position sur les AFD
les AFD je le rappelle ça a été créé en
2016 et ici même madame la défenseur de
droit vous auriez pu même le rappeler le
Sénat c'est vertueux jusqu'à présent de
limiter le recours à l'AFD mais si on a
autorisé la FD c'est parce que aussi on
a des problèmes de bonne administration
de la justice et quand vous avez des
occupés des
usages de cabane de cannabis
des occupations des sites d'immeubles de
des sonnettes d'alarme intempestives
dans les trains qui vont empêcher les
usagers de circuler normalement et qui
et qui
empeste leur vie si j'ose dire et bien
il y a des questions aussi de droit
aussi pour chacun d'aller devenir par
exemple donc il y a d'autres droits
derrière qu'il faut aussi protéger et
dire que uniquement que vous êtes contre
et que c'est attentatoire c'est une
atteinte
structurelle la liberté des personnes
qui sont concernées je crois aussi que
là aussi une remise en perspective
aurait été quand même bienvenu
un dernier exemple qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est celui vous avez parlé de
Mayotte Mayotte et l'exemple frappant
vous ne le voyez que du point de vue des
discriminations à l'égard des migration
et légales des conditions de ces jours
dans l'écran et autres institutions vous
savez il y a une population là-bas qui
subit 35% des migration illégales qui
n'arrivent plus à qui vit dans
l'insécurité permanente des choses je
crois aussi quand même qu'il faudrait
aussi le voir aussi du point de vue de
droit à la sécurité donc Madame la
défenseur j'aimerais vraiment que vous
mettiez un tout petit peu de balance
dans la complexité des choses parce que
il arrive que des questions soient
complexes il arrive qu'on est des
plusieurs droits qui sont doivent aussi
articuler pour que la société fasse
société précisément or aujourd'hui le
voir du point de vue uniquement de la
violence systémique d'un État qui
s'adresse à des personnes discriminées
c'est quand même un point de vue qui me
met qui mériterait d'être me semble-t-il
corrigé
merci monsieur et madame monsieur Durand
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Défenseur des droits vous le voyez la
difficulté pour nous qui sommes porteurs
de conviction parfois un peu un peu
vives c'est que
nous avons du mal parfois considérer que
votre impartialité ne soit pas la
stricte compatibilité avec notre nos
propres victions donc je vais essayer de
dépasser mes propres convictions pour
vous poser les questions qui
rebondissent sur ce que vous nous avez
indiqué d'abord je vous remercie pour
votre travail celui de vos équipes dire
que principalement en matière de
déontologie de la sécurité interne et de
contrôle externe des forces de l'ordre
vous recommandations sont toujours
utiles même si ce ne sont pas toujours
suivis par les pouvoirs publics avec la
contre je le général des lieux de
privation de liberté vous avez évoqué
les arrestations arbitraires pendant les
manifestations à Paris le préfet de
police c'est d'ailleurs rému de vos
critiques qu'il considèrent à justifier
est-ce que vous pouvez rappeler le
travail qui vous a permis d'arriver à
ces conclusions
j'avais parieur moi-même interpellé le
ministre je le rappelle du caractère
obligatoire du port du Rio il a
d'ailleurs transmis une consigne aux
forces de l'ordre qu'il a à nouveau
circularisé sur cette question et il
faut le remercier est-ce que vous avez
des éléments sur la nécessité pour les
citoyens de pouvoir identifier les
agents les membres de forces de l'ordre
avec lesquels ils échangent merci si
monsieur Durand madame Bassa merci
monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits je voudrais
féliciter vos vos travail et celui de
vos équipes et je suis même impressionné
comment avec un si petit budget vous
arrivez à faire tant de choses alors
d'abord
je voudrais
avoir quelques réponses
parce que c'est vrai que on critique
certaines choses mais est-ce qu'on
trouve des solutions c'est ça le
problème d'après un sondage du happyton
post un Français sur deux grandes
manifester en raison de la présence des
forces de l'or vous avez reçu
166 réclamations allant dans ce sens
dans quelle mesure vos recommandations à
l'attention des forces de police
sont-elles suivies par le service
concernés deuxièmement vous avez parlé
du problème des étrangers pour obtenir
un rendez-vous à la préfecture
croyez-moi mon petit cabinet reçoit
régulièrement
des demandes et même des demandes de
naturalisation de gens qui sont en
France depuis 40 ans qui remplissent
leur dossier leur en attendant le
rendez-vous le timbre sont
ils doivent payer de nouveau les timbres
refaire les photocopies etc vous voyez
quand nous c'est la terre au sénatrice
et dont ces gens on a quelque part
l'impression comme si on
faisait quelque chose qu'on ne devrait
pas faire c'est une façon en guillemets
je vais être vulgaire depuis sonné
pourquoi celui-là est pas l'autre vous
voyez mais nous passons beaucoup de
temps dans ce sens et il faudrait
franchement trouver une solution
et ensuite
enfin surtout une solution maintenant
avec
l'arrivée de l'été où les détenteurs et
de permis de résidence doivent partir en
vacances ils ont renouvelé ils ont
demandé le renouvellement de leur de
leur permis de séjour et il ne le
reçoivent pas ils ont des billets
achetés etc bon ensuite
je vous dois vous poser aussi une
question
c'est pas dans votre rapport puisque
c'est récent il y a le Sénat à adopter
le projet de loi justice réformant le
ministère de la Justice et le corps
judiciaire vous avez eu connaissance du
fameux article 3 tendant à activer à
distance tous types d'appareils
électronique quel regard portez-vous sur
cette mesure qui à mon modèle à vie est
fortement attentat à toi à notre vie
privée et enfin je
je sais que votre institution est
indépendante est nécessaire à la société
mais vous évoquez le manque de moyens
pour mener à bien certaines actions
notamment pour suivre les réclamations
qui augmentent d'années en année vous
avez dit que vous êtes un descente du
même disons du même potentiel que vous
indépendant en Europe qui sont bien
moins lotis que vous alors
avez-vous une estimation du budget
nécessaire pensez-vous de voir embaucher
davantage de collaborateurs vous avez
beaucoup de travail à faire vous l'avez
dit les discriminations ne regressent
pas hélas et il y a bien d'autres sujets
qui sur lesquels vous travaillez voilà
je vous remercie de nouveau et je vous
souhaite beaucoup de courage et vous
avez beaucoup de mérites merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame le Défenseur des droits je
voudrais vous saluer vous vos adjoints
et vos équipes pour le travail précieux
que vous faites chaque année qui nous
permet d'éclairer nos travaux
en venant ce matin ici je ne savais pas
ce que vous alliez nous dire comme
illustration de votre rapport d'activité
mais il se trouve que vous avez évoqué
la prime rénov et ce matin le quotidien
de ma région donc le Midi Libre fait sa
Une sur les ratés de la prime rénove
donc les perdants de la prime rénov
c'est la Une du journal et un dossier à
l'intérieur évoque une multitude de
témoignages comme celui que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure pour illustrer
l'absurdité de cette situation
en venant ici ce matin
je regardais les mails que j'ai reçu
encore hier et un cas qui illustre les
difficultés pour les personnes dans leur
relation avec
administration
une dame qui a la retraite fonctionnaire
civile du ministère des armées qui est
parti à la retraite depuis un an et qui
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait des
manques dans la carrière qui est la
sienne notamment pour les enfants
qu'elle a eu et donc depuis un an elle
envoie des courriers au ministère de
armées alors effectivement aujourd'hui
on a refermé les casernes donc il y a
plus de casernes dans la ville dans le
département où elle réside où elle a
travaillé elle est condamnée à elle
s'adresser au ministère des armées
depuis un an elle n'a pas de réponse et
cette dame se retrouve dans une
situation qui est assez délicate avec
une perte de plusieurs centaines d'euros
sur sa retraite vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la situation des étrangers je
vais moi aussi la l'illustrer la
prolonger par le sort des Français des
Français résidents dans l'Hexagone et
résident dans les outre-mer mais
résident aussi et surtout à l'étranger
vous avez évoqué la situation des
étrangers et je suis bien placé pour le
voir moi après moi et surtout pas la
rentrée lorsque les étudiants arrivent à
100 mètres de mon domicile et font la
queue devra la préfecture devant la
préfecture et au motif de fluidifier de
rationaliser le traitement des demandes
de titres de séjour à Montpellier comme
ailleurs on a externalisé et donc
aujourd'hui c'est développé un marché
noir des rendez-vous les gens se
connectent à minuit une heure du matin
prennent tous les rendez-vous et le prix
du rendez-vous c'est 200 ou 250 euros ça
c'est pour les étrangers mais je vais
aller beaucoup plus loin madame
Défenseur des droits pour vous parler
des Français les citoyens français qui
résident dans notre pays qui réside à
l'étranger lorsqu'il déposent leur
dossier pour renouveler un passeport ou
une carte d'identité parfois pour
voyager pour un événement familial qui
est fixé de longues dates pour un
mariage pour un baptême les dossiers qui
ont été déposés depuis quatre mois ou 6
mois je peux vous en citer des dizaines
auprès des municipalités qui se démènent
qui se démènent pour ouvrir des plats
des des tranches horaires beaucoup plus
larges beaucoup plus large mais les
municipalités servent de boîte aux
lettres vous le savez on dépose les
dossiers pour les passeports et les
cartes d'identité auprès d'elle et
ensuite elle les transmettent à la
préfecture et au ministère de
l'Intérieur et donc toute
l'insatisfaction tout le mécontentement
ce sont les municipalités qui l'assument
qui en hérite au quotidien alors que ce
ne sont pas elles qui fabriquent les
titres je voudrais vous parler des
Français qui résident à l'étranger ils
sont soumis hélas au même sort parce que
une funeste décision a été prise aussi
tous nos consulats à l'étranger en
sous-traité les rendez-vous pour le
dépôt des dossiers ce qui vaut pour les
étrangers souhaitant venir en France
vous aussi dans certains pays pour les
ressortissants français et donc j'ai des
exemples depuis deux ans de personnes
qui n'ont pas pu venir assister à des
mariages fixés depuis six mois au
mariage de leur petits-enfants en
déposant le dossier six mois en amont
n'ont pas obtenu les titres dans les
délais impartis tout cela pour vous dire
que les travaux que vous menez les
rapports d'activités que vous rendez
chaque année ne peut pas plaire à tout
le monde de toute façon vous n'avez pas
vocation à plaire à tout le monde vous
en avez pas vocation à plaire à tout le
monde vous avez vocation à faire bouger
les choses et naturellement vous n'êtes
pas là pour parler des trains qui
arrivent à l'heure mais vous êtes là
pour essayer de faire arriver les autres
trains qui sont pour l'instant en retard
à l'heure c'est votre rôle c'est notre
rôle avec vous en tant que pouvoir
public chacun dans le respect de ces
prérogatifs chacun dans le respect des
missions qui sont les siennes avec la
liberté de ton qui peut être le vôtre
comme le nôtre car je rappelle vous êtes
autorité administrative indépendante
vous n'êtes pas soumis à l'exécutif ni
au législatif d'ailleurs vous êtes
indépendant de risque et votre liberté
de temps mais elle vous appartient et si
elle nous plaît c'est bien si elle nous
plaît pas c'est pareil merci merci aux
chers collègues monsieur Tani m'avez
suali puis Monsieur benaroche et Madame
et non répondra
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la défenseur j'aimerais par saluer moi
aussi votre travail et le travail de vos
équipes ensuite vous dire que
les principes et valeurs que vous
défendez je crois que ici tout le monde
les défends et tout le monde est
d'accord avec avec ses principes et ses
valeurs
[Musique]
j'aimerais revenir sur la situation
à Mayotte que vous avez évoqué
en disant votre préoccupation par
rapport au décalage et aux éloignements
notamment
d'abord
je pense que il ne faut pas employer ce
mot de casage parce que il renvoie à de
l'illégalité
alors que dans le cadre de l'opération
les choses se font dans le respect de la
loi la loi que nous avons votée ici et
notamment la destruction de ces
bidonvilles est faite conformément au
dispositions de la loi élan que nous
avons travaillé ici à la Délégation
sénatorielle aux outre-mer
c'est dispositions ont été
soumises au Conseil d'État pour une
proposition de QPC le Conseil d'État
récemment à estimer que ça n'avait pas
la peine parce que les dispositions de
la loi Elan utilisée pour la destruction
des bidonvilles à Mayotte et bien
obéissent à la à notre à notre
Constitution
or je viens de regarder Wikipédia
lorsque je tape des casages ça renvoie à
des destructions illégales entreprises
par des habitants je pense que c'est
important
de commencer par par rappeler rappeler
ceci et de dire que ce qui se fait à
Mayotte aujourd'hui se fait conformément
à la loi et d'ailleurs
le préfet a eu l'occasion de suspendre
les destructions qui avaient été
programmées justement parce qu'il y a eu
des recours devant à la fois le tribunal
administratif et devant le juge civile
et ce n'est que lorsque ces juridictions
ont donné leur feu vert que les
procédures ont été ont été continué
j'aimerais également appeler
[Musique]
60% des reconduites à la frontière de la
France sont effectués à partir de ce
caillou
de rappeler que chaque jour
une salle de classe mais une salle de
classe 30 enfants donc il serait
nécessaire chaque jour pour suivre le
rythme de construire au moins une salle
de classe sans compter le phénomène dit
des quoi ça scolaire qui fait que une
fois que les communes les écoles ont
fait leur programmation de l'année et
bien cette période là qui commence
arrive des dizaines de centaines
d'enfants supplémentaires provenant des
Comores et on demande aux communes qui
sont parmi les plus pauvres de France et
bien de faire face du jour au lendemain
à ces centaines de d'élèves
supplémentaires chaque année donc
comment
comment Mayotte les collectivités de
Mayotte s'en sortent-elles et tout en
étant
d'accord avec les principes les valeurs
que vous avez rappelé
il faut aussi mettre sur la balance
ces éléments il y en a d'autres mais ce
sont ceux contenus du peu de temps qui
nous a imparti que je voulais aussi
évoquer ici et finir par vous dire que
l'opération en bouchou qui a fait peur
et qui a fait beaucoup parler avant même
qu'elle n'ait commencé plaît beaucoup
aux Maoré qui se disent enfin ça va
peut-être bouger enfin on est peut-être
en train de s'occuper de la situation de
Mayotte qui fait que
nous subissons une immigration
clandestine insensée et insupportable
pour les Maoris et les Maoris et pour
nos collectivités
si Monsieur Guy benaroche merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Défenseur des
droits je voulais tout d'abord
vous remercier et vous féliciter pour le
travail de votre institution
votre institution heureux un peu
particulier quel exercice avec toute la
dépendance souhaitée et nécessaire en
fonction justement de la fonction qui
lui a été donnée
sans se substituer ni au travail du
législateur ni au travail des élus ni au
travail de l'administration sans avoir
les pouvoirs de ces de ces différents
organes mais avec la qualité
d'une impartialité que pour ma part
j'estime certaines et respecter à la
place que vous devez avoir et à la place
que vous occupez je vais d'abord vous en
féliciter
j'ai deux questions et une petite
remarque ma petite remarque ce que vous
avez dit sur le fait que la
dématérialisation doit être accompagnée
en permanence par une devise qui est un
guichet un humain et quelque chose qui
est à l'atmotiv de toutes les prises de
position sur la numérisation sur la
dématérialisation de mon groupe et que
la réponse que j'ai systématiquement
j'ai c'est fait et je vous le dis et
vous le permettez de le constater ce
n'est pas le cas et cela aboutit à tout
un tas de situations
inextricable et inacceptable il faut
répéter absolument
ce leitmotiv deux questions
que vous avez ou qui ont été légèrement
évoqué la première sur les amendes
forfaitaires délictuelles je pense que
le président buffet avait évoqué je
pense pas que vous ayez répondu
[Musique]
ma question est la suivante la lampe
effectivement souhaitait une
généralisation initiale de cette
procédure au Sénat nous l'avons limité
nous la retransformer en extension
néanmoins en ce qui nous concerne
l'arbitraire et la disparité de
traitement était une crête y compris
pour l'extension il me semble que
d'après les premiers signalements et les
premiers retours d'expérimentation cette
crête s'avère justifiée
dans un communiqué RSA vous avez demandé
de mettre fin à la mode forfaitaire
délictuelle je voulais savoir quels
étaient au fait les argumentaires pour
mettre fin à la mode forfaitaire
délictuelle deuxième question sur ce qui
est parfaitement dans votre rôle à
savoir des recommandations sur le
respect des règles de déontologie par
les forces de sécurité
vous l'avez rappelé plusieurs fois y
compris qu'il fallait encadrer les
comptes d'identité les fouilles et les
filtrage
vous avez alerté sur la problématique
développée par ce gouvernement alors je
cite le ministère de l'Intérieur le
préfet de police avant affirmé qu'il
n'avait pas d'interpellation préventive
des manifestants par contre le
porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
Veyrat avec quand même lui affirmé qu'il
pouvait avoir des arrestations faites
pour contrôler si Olivier Véran qui l'a
dit bon
donc ma question porte sur les
interpellations qui seraient préventive
de personnes aux abords de manifestation
je rappelle faits diverses qui a eu un
peu parce que ça touchait pas des
écologistes donc du coup il a eu un peu
de succès c'était celui sur l'histoire
des jeunes autrichiens qui avaient été
placés en garde à vue avec des dizaines
d'autres personnes sans aucune raison
voilà donc je souhaiterais savoir avec
le recul et après votre prise de
position du mois de mars si vous estimez
qu'il y a eu un progrès qui a été fait
dans la gestion de cette problématique
si des leçons ont été tirés et si des
changements de procédure à votre
connaissance ont été mis en place
si monsieur benaroche je crois que on a
fait le tour l'ensemble des questions
madame la défenseur vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup à tous pour vos questions
d'abord en introduction je voudrais
réinsister sur notre impartialité mon
impartialité et la question du travail
objectif parce que nous menons des
enquêtes en contradictoires et nous
entendons l'ensemble des parties donc
notre travail est tout à fait objectif
et impartial je ne nie pas les
difficultés des forces de l'ordre et de
Mayotte et d'ailleurs dans les avis que
nous rendons nous le disons à chaque
fois et c'est vrai je sais l'un de vous
la dit je ne vois que ce qui ne va pas
et c'est d'ailleurs l'institution a été
créée pour ça et on ne m'a pas demandé
de faire des rapports d'état des lieux
complets mais bien de rapport à partir
de ce que nous observons dans nos
réclamations pour faire un certain
nombre de recommandations ça c'était en
propos un introductif
d'autre part donc Monsieur Bonhomme
toutes les démocraties ont des
institutions équivalentes à la nôtre
toutes toutes voilà donc ça c'est
vraiment un élément important de
démocratie manifestement vous avez lu
notre rapport manuel en revanche
manifestement vous n'avez pas lu les
avis que nous avons rendus je pense au
schéma de maintien de l'ordre je pense à
ce que je dis sur les questions de
déontologie des forces de sécurité
d'abord pour vous répondre sur la
question des maires en fait ce que nous
disons dans ces cas-là on a parfaitement
conscience de la difficulté pour les
maires de récupérer les créances des
parents ce sur quoi je me prononce à
chaque fois c'est sur l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant et ça vous allez
être d'accord avec moi que c'est
vraiment pas optimal d'enlever un enfant
de la cantine devant tout le monde de
dire devant tous les autres élèves à
l'enfant c'est comme ça que démarre le
harcèlement scolaire très clairement de
dire devant à un enfant devant tout le
monde tes parents n'ont pas payé la
cantine ce sont des éléments qui font
démarrer le harcèlement scolaire c'est
ça que nous dénonçons et c'est ça qui
est important c'est l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant et c'est la seule question
sur lequel je me prononce et bien sûr
qu'il faut que les mères récupèrent les
créances et il y a moyen de s'adresser
aux parents sans dénoncer l'envoi
l'enfant devant tout le monde et quand
nous sommes intervenus c'est précisément
sur ces questions là ça c'est le premier
point le maintien de l'ordre alors
toutes mes interventions publiques ont
commencé par condamner toute forme de
violence j'ai toujours dit que c'était
la première chose je condamne toute
forme de violence c'est le premier point
deuxièmement le principe du maintien de
l'ordre c'est la liberté de manifester
c'est le premier objectif et je redis
aussi et je le dis à chaque fois que je
suis consciente des difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontées les forces
de l'ordre et de la violence auquel ils
sont confrontés les réclamations que
vous n'avons reçues depuis les
manifestations sur sur la retraite
effectivement des personnes qui disent
et donc je la pour le coup j'ai toujours
utilisé le conditionnel dans les
réclamations que nous recevons parce
qu'en fait nous sommes au début des
enquêtes et donc je ne peux pas me
prononcer et nous nous prononcerons il
nous faut quand même le temps de faire
des enquêtes en contradictoire si je
vous donne en gros le détail des 169
réclamations il y a un tiers ou assez
vite nous n'avons pas les éléments pour
dire qu'il peut y avoir non respect de
la déontologie des de sécurité nous en
avons un tiers ou l'affaire est porté
devant les tribunaux il nous faut
l'autorisation du procureur pour
instruire donc tout ça va prendre du
temps et nous avons un tiers sur lequel
nous sommes en train d'enquêter et
d'ailleurs je remercie la préfecture de
police de Paris et le préfet de police
qui nous répondent de façon très rapide
sur les éléments que nous que nous
demandons les réclamations portées
effectivement sur des personnes qui
disent avoir été privées de liberté dans
des nazes 100 points de sortie des
personnes qui disent avoir été victimes
de violence des interpellations suivies
considérées par le réclamment de garde à
vue arbitraire et la nouveauté c'est des
journalistes empêché de faire leur
travail ça c'est des réclamations
nouvelles que nous n'avions pas que nous
n'avions pas avant et d'autre part l'un
de vous me demandait si nous avons des
réponses sur les recommandations que
nous faisons nous sommes en échange très
régulier à la fois avec les forces de
l'ordre avec avec le ministère nous
avons fait des recommandations dans le
schéma de maintien de l'or nous avons
été suivis sur un certain nombre de
recommandations l'identification visible
du Rio il y a des progrès on est
d'accord nous avons encore vu des
difficultés sur le rio non visible mais
globalement nous observons plutôt des
progrès et je voudrais d'ailleurs
monsieur le sénateur parce que vous vous
intéressez à la déontologie des forces
de l'ordre vous rappelez que dans une
des décisions que nous avons rendues sur
un jeune maîtrisé au moment d'une
manifestation au sol maîtrisé qui
continuent à être frappé par un policier
nous ce que nous étudions c'est la
nécessité et la proportionnalité de la
force utilisée quand la personne est
maintenue elle n'est ni nécessaire ni
professionnelle en l'occurrence policier
était casqués cagoulés sans héréhieu
visible aucune des forces de l'ordre à
côté les policiers l'encadrement n'a été
capable de nous dire qui c'était ça si
c'est pas délétère pour la confiance
qu'on a dans nos forces de l'ordre je
pense que c'est particulièrement
délétère mais nous observons plutôt des
progrès dans la visibilité des Rio mais
pas suffisamment il n'y a pas de de
doute là-dessus sur l'usage dlbd
pourquoi nous nous sommes prononcés
contre d'abord parce que nous avons
aussi regardé ce que font ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays européens
figurez-vous que de nombreux pays y ont
renoncé parce qu'il y a des risques
d'atteinte physique et ce que nous
observons dans les déclara dans les
réclamations c'est des personnes qui ont
perdu un œil qui ont un bras
complètement habillé c'est juste pour ça
que nous nous prononçons que nous ne
sont contre le donc je pense au
contraire que ce que nous disons en
disant à chaque fois de ne jamais
généraliser nous disons bien que nous
voyons des difficultés ponctuelles et
que nous souhaitons qu'il y ait des
sanctions quand il y a des difficultés
je tiens à dire d'ailleurs que depuis
que je suis arrivé nous avons fait 12
demandes de poursuites disciplinaires
pour les forces de l'ordre nous avons
obtenu cette réponse du ministre de
l'intérieur les cinq autres c'est normal
elles sont en cours d'examens il y a eu
quatre ouvertures d'enquête avec rappel
des textes alors ça évidemment pour nous
ça n'allait pas suffisamment loin parce
que si nous demandions des poursuites
disciplinaires si c'est juste un rappel
au texte nous le faisons nous-mêmes et
nous pensons que la sanction devait
pouvez aller plus loin mais nous sommes
en échange régulier je voudrais aussi
vous préciser que nos décisions les plus
importantes justement quand on demande
des sanctions des poursuites
disciplinaires passent devant un collège
dans lequel il y a des personnalités qui
sont nommées par le président du Sénat
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
la Cour de cassation et le Conseil
d'État et nous avons d'ailleurs dedans
un ancien un ancien DGPN directeur
général de la police nationale les
décisions depuis que je suis arrivée
sont prises à l'unanimité sauf dans deux
situations nous avons été amenés à voter
mais elles sont prises en général
absolument à l'unanimité donc voilà ce
que j'observe et je pense que en 10 ans
ce qui ne va pas nous contribuons à
rétablir à rétablir la rétablir la
confiance sur la question des
occupations illicites de logement je
n'ai jamais dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
problème je je d'ailleurs je pense qu'il
y a un problème de d'accès au logement
de façon générale de manque de
construction de logements et entre
autres de logements soci est très
sociaux à des prix abordables
particulièrement dans les zones tendues
donc dans notre avis nous disons bien
que il y a un problème mais on est bien
en confrontation effectivement de droit
vous avez raison le droit à la propriété
qu'on signale tout à fait dans notre
avis d'ailleurs il est absolument
lisez-le il est absolument écrit voilà
oui je pense que ça me paraît et donc il
y a pas de doute simplement il y a un
autre droit qui est en parallèle qui est
le droit à la vie privée et que nous
mettons en confrontation et ce sur quoi
en fait nous sommes inquiets c'est
l'amande qui pourrait être mise si la
personne et qui peut monter jusqu'à 7500
euros si l'append si la personne reste
dans les lieux alors qu'il y a eu
demande d'expulsion moi ce que j'observe
ça devient une criminalisation de la
pauvreté et je suis forcément inquiète
de de cette question
sur les les sur les AFD les amendes les
amandes forfaitaires délictuelles en
fait si nous nous sommes prononcés c'est
par rapport aux réclamations que nous
avons reçues que nous avons reçu dans ce
dans ce domaine
en fait c'est la complexité des règles
de contestation qui nous inquiète c'est
que nous avons eu des réclamants qui ont
voulu contester une AFD donc ce qui est
effectivement possible sauf qu'ils ont
pas fait l'envoi en recommandé ou en
utilisant le formulaire ça a été
considéré comme il recevable et ses AFD
séparent parce que c'est quand même
inscrit sur le casier judiciaire donc ça
a un impact qui n'est pas négligeable et
j'ai bien conscience aussi de la
question de désengorger les tribunaux
mais moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'en
fait c'est plutôt des populations
éloignées du droit et plus précaires qui
vont pas pouvoir faire valoir leurs
droits parce que l'obligation de
consignation préalable c'est c'est aussi
une difficulté pour un certain nombre de
personnes et puis on a eu plusieurs
situations de problèmes de réception de
la vie de l'AFD parce qu'elle est
envoyée par courrier simple et qu'il y a
des moments où ça n'arrive pas
auprès de la personne je peux vous
donner d'ailleurs un exemple c'était une
personne qui avait été verbalisée pour
défaut d'assurance alors qu'en fait elle
était assurée vous n'avez pas
l'assurance sur elle ce qui est
effectivement enfin je veux dire une
faute mais dans ces cas-là il y a il y a
une contravention qui est émise mais
mais elle était elle était bien assurée
et donc ça contestation a été jugée et
recevable car elle n'a pas utilisé le le
formulaire une autre qui était malade et
hospitalisée à ce moment-là qui donc n'a
pas fait la réclamation à temps en fait
si on se prononce là-dessus c'est à
partir de réclamation qu'on reçoit et
effectivement en principal nous avons
demandé la suppression des AFD mais en
subsidiaire nous avons à ce fait un
certain nombre de recommandations
justement sur les questions que je viens
de soulever pour que ce soit plus clair
pour les pour les pour les réclamants
sur
je pense que recommandations forces de
l'ordre je pense que j'ai à peu près le
tour de des questions que vous m'aviez
que vous m'aviez posé là-dessus sur la
question des des rendez-vous en
préfecture d'abord je suis assez
persuadée que dans vos permanences vous
voyez des choses assez équivalentes à ce
qu'on peut voir sur ces difficultés de
rendez-vous en préfecture sur ma prime
rénov sur des choses comme ça et je suis
vous savez je vais régulièrement voir
nos délégués sur le terrain dans ce
qu'on appelle nous des collégiales on
réunit les délégués d'un département ou
d'une région pour échanger avec eux ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est que les
deux sujets qui arrivent tout de suite
dès que j'arrive ils me disent on en
peut plus des préfectures qui nous
répondent pas sur des situations
dramatiques et la même chose sur ma
prime rénov voilà ce sont les deux et je
pense que ça vous le voyez aussi vous
dans vos dans vos permanences sur la
question là de la loi sur la justice et
de l'intelligence artificielle en fait
on travaille beaucoup avec la CNIL aussi
sur ces questions
nous notre grande crainte c'est aussi
tous les biais discriminatoires et je
pense qu'il faut beaucoup plus de
transparence je trouve qu'on voit les
difficultés en ce moment d'ailleurs sur
sur parcoursup et sur et sur les
affectations ce qu'il faudrait c'est
plus de transparence sur comment ça
fonctionne pour que les les gens
comprennent et nous on y voit toujours
un risque discriminatoire qui peut être
et qui peut entre autres discriminer des
jeunes en situation de handicap et nous
le voyons et est-ce que ce qui est
absolument nécessaire c'est la question
de la transparence et surtout la
discrimination elle peut être dans la
façon dont on fait fonctionner
l'intelligence artificielle mais elle
peut devenir discriminatoire voilà donc
on a quelques quelques inquiétudes sur
ce sur ce sujet
les problèmes de retraite monsieur
Bourget que vous avez évoqué alors on a
pas mal de réclamations dans ce domaine
une situation très grave aux Antilles
avec des réclamants qui passent un an et
demi deux ans sans aucune
des pensions de réversion qui sont pas
versées alors ça aussi sur le territoire
métropolitain des difficultés et
évidemment c'est excessivement délétère
vous l'avez dit des personnes qui du
coup se retrouvent avec des revenus
diminués je vous incite dans ces cas-là
à nous saisir je ne promets pas toujours
des miracles parce qu'il faut aussi
qu'on ait des réponses dans ces cas-là
de lactave mais n'hésitez pas vous avez
aussi évoqué la question des Français de
l'étranger sachez qu'on a quatre
délégués qui ont pour mission justement
de traiter les réclamations des Français
de l'étranger et effectivement nous
observons la même chose que vous sur des
difficultés d'accès sur les demandes de
renouvellement de passeport de français
les cartes d'identité on continue à voir
des difficultés et sur lequel ça empêche
les personnes vous l'avez dit mais ça
nous on a aussi des personnes ça les
empêcher d'aller un enterrement d'un
proche ou aller accompagner un proche
sur des sur des sur des sur des fins de
vie et je redis dans tout ça
effectivement je vois ce qui ne ce qui
ne va pas le dernier point que j'ai
peut-être pas encore
évoquer c'est la question de Mayotte et
je vous remercie beaucoup sur vos propos
sur Mayotte nous avons
évidemment dans ces cas là aussi on voit
ce qui va pas et moi je vais vous dire
en gros ce qui ne va pas c'est que en
fait ben non la loi elle est pas
toujours appliquée on a eu des
situations où la loi elle en a pas été
appliquée
assez assez récemment avant le démarrage
de wembushu et où il y a eu justement
alors je suis d'accord avec vous que le
terme de décalage n'est pas bon mais
destruction de de bidonville mais là en
l'occurrence c'était un des casages qui
étaient illégal il y avait pas eu de la
loi Elan elle est claire il faut qu'il y
ait une proposition d'hébergement et il
n'y avait pas eu justement de
proposition d'hébergement puis après
nous ce qu'on observe parce que donc
vous savez qu'on a une délégation qui
est allé sur place de juriste on a
quatre délégués sur place notre chef de
pôle régional qui est basé à La Réunion
qui va régulièrement à Mayotte donc on
est on est en lien direct avec les
difficultés qui qui peuvent qui peuvent
arriver et et donc ce que nous observons
c'est justement les moments où le droit
n'est pas appliqué j'ai en tête alors
donc il y a la question de la de la
destruction des bidonvilles et de la du
relogement enfin du relogement de
l'hébergement qui est proposé au pape
proposé on a observé aussi des
difficultés dans l'enquête sociale
faites pour justement essayer de
proposer un hébergement qui soit qui
soit adapté aux personnes on observe
aussi que tant cet hébergement est
proposé à l'autre bout de l'île pour la
question de la scolarisation des enfants
c'est excessivement compliqué il nous
continuerons à défendre l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant sur ces questions
là et puis je voudrais vous citer
quelques situations sur lequel on a été
on a été alerté on a été saisi d'une
situation d'un enfant qui pendant deux
ans qui a été trouvé dans un caniveau et
a été surnommé bébé X sans lui donner un
nom sans une protection de cet enfant
c'est d'une violence inouïe on le sait
pour sa propre identité nous avons été
saisi aussi d'un jeune de et on a eu
plusieurs situations comme ça je vous le
site mais d'un jeune de 15 ans français
qui est arrêté par les forces de l'ordre
qui n'a pas de désidenté sur lui mais
qui dit bien je suis mineur je suis
français qui est mis par les forces de
l'ordre majeur Comoriens expulsé aux
Comores aucun lien familial aux Comores
il passe 17 jours à la rue avant qu'on
arrive à ce qu'il soit rapatriés ce
n'est pas la seule situation que nous
avons eu comme celle-là nous avons eu
des enfants rattachés arbitrairement à
des adultes qui aussi étaient des
enfants français en situation et de
parents en situation légale donc oui en
fait moi ce que je vois c'est les
moments où justement ça ne va pas et où
les droites sont pas respectés donc je
suis pas tout à fait aussi optimiste que
vous sur la question que les droits sont
respectés non justement on observe et
c'est là dessus qu'on parle et je vous
redis c'est là que je vois que que ce
qui ne va pas on est saisi quand les
choses n'ont pas été faites qu'on n'a
pas été faites correctement je pense que
j'ai répondu à peu près à l'intégralité
de vos questions merci Madame question
nous arrivons au terme de votre audition
peut-être sans vouloir être un mot de
conclusion absolu considéré que nous
sommes cela a été dit tout à l'heure par
un solide tous d'accord sur les
principes de droit qui sont les nôtres
que ces principes soient respectés il
n'y a aucun doute
la question reste cependant et je vous
la pose très librement
c'est de cas particulier d'en faire une
exception qui remettent en cause le
principe
c'est ça la difficulté ce qui peut y
avoir effectivement
des cas particuliers ou la règle de
droit n'a pas été respectée ou pas
respecté ou parce que l'État lui-même
n'a pas mis en œuvre les moyens
suffisants pour que ça soit respecté on
va pas rentrer dans le détail de tout ça
mais c'est pas mais ça ne peut pas
remettre en cause les principes généraux
qui ont été établis et les règles à
caractère général donc c'est en ça je
crois que la commission des lois
aime l'équilibre voilà merci à vous
excellente journée ah oui Monsieur
Bonhomme avant de partir je crois que si
vous permettez monsieur le Président
pour l'intérêt de la discussion
j'aimerais juste avoir un petit droit de
suite parce que j'ai entendu les petites
suite alors allons-y Très Petite Suisse
mais je crois que c'est intéressant
parce que je me situe pas ici comme
ayant le mauvais rôle de celui qui
a le rôle de défendre des choses qui
seraient indéfendables pas du tout et
quand les cas madame la Défenseur des
droits que j'ai pris en cause c'est
qu'il faudrait pas à partir de d'une
situation vous avez pris le cas de la
cantine effectivement il y a un
municipale qui est le maire a cru
qu'avec le policier municipal mais on
peut le comprendre parce que quand vous
savez la fonction de masque comme elle
les prenante on peut faire des erreurs
de cette appréciation et donc en faire
un cas d'humiliation de l'élève je vous
l'accorde mais il faudrait pas partir de
cette situation qui bien heureusement
demeure tout à fait marginale
exceptionnel en faire un cas de figure
générale pour pour aborder le sujet
voilà cette simplement une remise en
perspective et je crois que l'intérêt de
notre discussion ce matin dans le
ministre madame la ministre vous voyez
madame a Défenseur des droits c'est
c'est précisément quand même de vous
demander quelques explications parce que
c'est la contrepartie naturelle j'allais
dire de votre statut et moi je suis pas
ici pour vous dresser des couronnes
faire le parti pris un concert de loin
je suis là pour vous donner des
explications ma vision des choses je
pense que l'intérêt de la discussion
c'est précisément de confronter les
visions des choses voyez-vous et si je
me permettais un peu de bien pertinence
je me dirais que peut-être si vous aviez
dans une vie antérieure vous avez une
parcours tout à fait remarquable avec la
télé carbone mais vous ayez été un jour
peut-être l'exercer les fonctions de mer
voire de ministre je ne parle pas de
présence publique ça vous aurait
peut-être donné ça vous aurait donné
peut-être une vision un tout petit peu
différente sur la difficulté un certain
cas dans décider de faire des arbitrages
y compris budgétaire et peut-être que ça
modernerait aussi parfois la vie plus
développée ça coupe donc vous êtes
commission des lois le sait ce matin
juste vous répondre sur quelques sur
quelques éléments d'abord effectivement
je pense avoir une certaine connaissance
des situations dans les quartiers et des
situations de de pauvreté effectivement
vous avez raison vu d'un côté vous savez
qu'on a fait un rapport mairie justement
sur tout le travail que font nos
délégués en médiation et sur lequel on
peut être très utile et deuxièmement sur
je sur les cas que je vous ai cité on en
fait d'ailleurs pas une généralité mais
on y va surtout que quand il y a eu
atteinte au droit des enfants quand la
mairie cherche à récupérer les sommes
que doivent les parents je veux dire
là-dessus on n'a pas de doute si on y va
c'est que nous on considère qu'il y a eu
une atteinte au droit des enfants et
puis du coup ça rejoint ce que ce que
vous disiez est-ce que en fait on fait
pas de cas particulier des généralités
alors à aucun moment parce que d'abord
je dis bien que je vois que ce qui ne va
pas mais je vois que qu'une partie de ce
qui va passer j'ai parfaitement
conscience qui a une grande partie de la
population qui ne nous saisit pas qui ne
sait pas qu'on existe et qui ne sait pas
comment faire donc en fait on envoie
qu'une partie mais à partir de là on
voit des difficultés qu'on voit c'était
très intéressant sur ma prime rénov
d'ailleurs la façon dont on voit d'un
seul coup l'augmentation des
réclamations et c'est à partir de là et
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu vous dire
dès le début que le législateur il nous
a vraiment donné comme mission de
traiter les réclamations mais de
promouvoir les droits et les libertés et
de faire des rapports sur les
difficultés qu'on observait donc là
dessus vraiment je cherche pas à
généraliser mais par contre à faire un
certain nombre de recommandations pour
que les réclamations que nous avons ne
viennent plus sur ces dernières aspect
on terminera là le constat que je fais
depuis quelques années je suis
parlementaire c'est que l'État français
a souvent de bonnes idées même de grands
projets mais parfois tout à fait
incapable de se donner les moyens de les
réaliser et que le système si bien conçu
chute parce que on se donne pas les
moyens d'aller au bout des choses il y a
mille exemples de cette nature on ferait
mieux d'en faire moins étonner les
moyens pour que ça fonctionne bien sûr
ces paroles non prophétiques je vous
souhaite une bonne journée